one of the latest ventures for him is a
curated set of cards inside a tops
nationwide release of cards he is Gary
Vaynerchuk how are you Gary well rich
I'm okay but last night's Cavey
situation and my Knicks future had me a
little bit on tilt all right Gary
you don't really you're not really
because I saw your tweet last night we
can get right into this right off the
bat if you'd like your tweet last night
was sign up to the max and then you had
an apple next to it to give him a max
deal you really think that you really
still want to do that but that's that's
crack of dawn you sent that one Gary I
believe that that is my official point
of view that if I was the owner to next
for the GM I would sign KB right this
minute
to a max deal but Gary you just went
through a year and a half of no
porzingis because he blew his knee out
so you're gonna blow out porzingis just
to get a max deal window for somebody
coming off of an Achilles that you
probably won't have for a full year
anyway you do that that is yeah right I
don't post things that I wouldn't do and
I and I think you know me well enough
that I'm obsessed with being
historically correct
getting some reshares I'm not trying to
troll I genuinely think it's a very
smart decision to sign Kevin Durant to a
max deal right now and amortize that one
year out I actually think if you think
about it logically look what's gonna be
life is about alternatives so the
alternative is we go trade every young
asset right for Anthony Davis or you
sign Katy to next deal you get somebody
else to a max deal or a good contract or
you wait if you can't get quired or
Kyrie which looks likely you can't and
what happens is you have Katie's
presence in the ecosystem which gives
hope to the fan base it mentors the
cabin oxes and the Mitchells of the
world you're likely not going to be that
great you might even find yourself back
in the lottery we have a new lottery
system that allows us to get massive
upside if it bounces well but even if it
doesn't you have Katy coming back he's a
shooter rich he's a shooter like he's
going to be more than fine
it's modern medicine he's young
everyone's he's old that's fine but you
know this rich because you and I are
than these kids yes 31 today is not 31
the way you and I grew up right and so
yes I think he gives you four or five
ridiculous years which is what you're
kind of looking for yeah I would sign
him tomorrow unless of course he just
stays put with uh with the Warriors for
a year he t he cannot opt out and then
maybe create some sort of window for
next year somebody can be brilliant and
come to him right now and offer from a
max deal mm-hmm all right Gary
Vaynerchuk here on the Rich Eisen show
all right Gary what's good what's the
scope of your tops national release of
cards that you've got a curated set of
cards inside I know you were talking
about trading cards last time you were
here I give you the floor on what why
are you so interested in this well rich
because I basically am an entrepreneur
because of baseball cards and I'm 43 and
that classic 87 88 89 those great known
as the just junk waxy or the cards
aren't worth anything
but it was the height of popularity of
sports cards sports cards are the thing
that I most associate myself and my
youth to and if you told 15 year old me
that I would have a trading card
literally in packs of tops I would you
know it missus thing this is easily the
single coolest thing I'm ever gonna do
in my life outside of buying the New
York Jets does not say when the Gary Vee
says in the back of the Jose Ramirez
card it does not say anything about you
buying the New York Jets but I would
never put that on any back of a card
right now so this is what top
entrepreneurs in baseball that's what
this Gary these top entrepreneurs in
baseball set one in every 18 packs
there's an insert Gary B's top
entrepreneur in baseball lose you know
and I was on my team went through a lot
of data and you know it's a fun set
because four out every Alex Bregman
there's a Trevor may because Trevor just
happens to be a phenomenal entrepreneur
he you know may not end up being the
most valuable baseball card because
middle relievers don't really dictate
the market but I really put a lot of
effort into who's an actual entrepreneur
and then
you have one and every 18 packs chance
to get that insert and then above and
beyond that there's a autographs and
special insurance one every five
thousand packs is the dual auto rich you
can go to a store right now by a pack of
top series two baseball cards and
possibly pull out a Derek Jeter Gary Vee
dual Auto card so his autograph is on it
along with yours in the packs are all
twelve guys that are into that I picked
because I picked two icons Randy Johnson
yes become an entrepreneur in his
photography business right yeah and
Derek Jeter who's well documented in all
his entrepreneurial ventures are the two
classic guys and and so there is a dual
lotto Randy do Auto me do Auto Bryce
Harper Alex Bregman Trevor may Jose
Ramirez amazing ah and I could it's you
know Chris Iannetta who happens to be an
entrepreneur in the wine world which is
my former life so I'm super fired up
about this what happened was a year ago
two years ago I started saying baseball
card sports cards are coming back a year
ago I got really loud by the way I'm
opening packs as I speak to you
Alex Bregman game-used Jersey insert
card so I'm excited here I decided they
were gonna come back because of sneaker
flipping gambling I thought vintage
cards were unbelievably under priced
especially in basketball as it continues
to create demand in Asia and other
things and so Jordan rookies green
rookies Oscar Jerry West icons and then
obviously the nice tars the the hardens
the Kobe's the the Durant's the by the
way one of things I'm most excited about
it Durant is out for the season
I'm gonna buy an uncomfortable amount of
Durant rookie cards over the next year
Chuck here on the Rich Eisen show so
what is what is the value of some of
these cards that you're pulling out of
this pack if you just go ahead and throw
it in I guess some sort of some sort of
yeah some sort of coating or some sort
of protective covering Gary you're
talking about the grading system so I
don't know yet they just came out and so
the value of these cards is going to be
figured out hmm I'd like to think that
they'll be some demand for my you know
from entrepreneurs I want my insert
so we'll see how that goes I mean the
market decides on that right and so
we'll see I mean there's a big national
convention in the last week of July in
Chicago I I bought a table rich I'm
literally spending four days at the
National Convention as a dealer like
back in my teenage days so I'm excited
about hustling there and we will see
what the cards are incredible so if
somebody real quick I call Jess for
interrupting but obviously we talked
about it last time a little bit when I
was rude when I'm really getting hot in
this I noticed your tweet about finding
your cards I saw a bunch of people
jumping in that was a it's the emotion
and nostalgia that really drives this
this hobby and every kind of 20 years
get bubbles back up and becomes a
dominant force I also think there's a
really interesting thing I've had over
50 to 100 mothers reach out to me and
tell me the reasons they're excited or
even pushing their kids into sports
cards is they're looking for
alternatives to technology and they like
the idea that their kids are spending
time opening packs putting them into
binders trading with their friends in
real life I think the fear mongering of
technology is going to lead to a little
bit of market dynamics as well
interesting so when you say technologies
like get them off a screen which
obviously my wife and I are constantly
focused on the amount of screen time
televisions iPads iPods or whatever iPod
touches my kids are on
so you think moms are concerned about
that giving them cards and is going to
be a thing if you will over the next
couple years and also being mom be way
more into entrepreneurship than my
generation I was luckily in a place
where my mom did believe in it and Oh
Pam I just pulled the garyvee insert
it's Ian Kinsler I'm fired up Ian
Kinsler just pulled it rich fired up TV
three ball player well yeah I haven't
watched much Padres baseball lately to
be honest with you Gary but I do know
he's on the Padres now interestingly
enough I just took out my old stride
right shoe box that I have next to my my
desk here filled with cards
and I have no idea what they're worth
you say they're junk is what you're
saying are you saying they're junk you
know I'll give you 10 bucks or something
you and I are friends I'll give you 12
[ __ ] I gave you back all your strength
I got a yes over there and it's pretty
good condition right it's not bad
I mean the grating thing has been huge
right now the happy pills were a ton of
stuff like demanders in our all-time
highs our scrutiny right now about
ratings which i think you know you know
trimming cards and things that nature
very important conversation
I think the hobby needs to go through on
top of that I think a lot of people
gonna get caught up in the Xion hype and
all this new stuff right a lot of people
look this is right now we're in the
potential of the next junk box era
because I think there's me a ton of
cards made demand is going up the car
companies are gonna do well but I want
to caution everybody getting into the
Hobby to be thoughtful about supply and
demand
my recommendation is soccer and
basketball because of the global demand
my recommendation is older cards because
of the supply and demand so I personally
I'm sitting with you right now and I
just got delivered 83 Luka Ricky cards
grated perfectly now I think Luca is
going to be an all-time player so I'm
okay with making an investment on him
because if I'm right that he's all-time
top 50 top 25 then that plays out but
for the most part what I'm really
investing in is you know you know
Dominique Wilk it actually cream I just
bought you like this rich I just bought
for like I think $17,000 actually just
got delivered it's here
yeah it'll pull it out I just bought a
1957 Bill Russell rookie card rated 7
and how much does that cost $17,000
everything what Chuck god bless you now
I think Bill Russell is a not only a
basketball icon and I hate him by the
way cuz he's a Celtics he's a basketball
icon but more importantly one thing I
know is this is my thesis in general I
don't want to share this on your air
because of the mass amount of audience
and I haven't bought enough yet to like
get as many as I want but in a world run
to bring some value and I adore you I
think one of the most underpriced cards
in the world right now is Kaepernick
rookie cards no kidding yes obviously
his on the field looks is extremely
unlikely that that's gonna play out
however I believe he will in 15 or 20
years I knew that the Exide in 15 20
years 30 years will be one of the most
important cultural icons to a generation
and I believe his rookie cards will can
you know on the next cycle which I'm now
talking about my son's daughter or son
collecting right Kaepernick rookie cards
are gonna be grossly grossly higher than
they are now so that's one card I'm
looking at and that's gonna look at Bill
I don't I think you're starting to see
you know you know we saw Busey come out
I think as America ironically is taking
a step
people think see us in a tough spot now
where we see the world definitely I
think some of the icons of acceptance
and inclusion in sports will continue to
grow in overall theme not just sports
Fame my intuition is there is a
documentary to be made in the next 30
years that really tells bill Russell's
story in a way that transcends just
sports which creates even more demand
for his rookie card as one of the
executions of people paying homage to
him and so Bill Russell is very high on
my list of underpriced cards and
obviously you know $17,000 may make
people choke on being under price but
like fine art I'm looking right now at a
1957 Bill Russell card that looks
beautiful in great shape and even though
it's $17,000 I genuinely believe I'm
gonna look back at this interview one
day and tweet it or whatever the
platform is in 30 years when this is a
hundred thousand dollar card and will be
considered historically correct yeah are
you the man I appreciate the time
Congrats on again on the sneak or two
with k-swiss the double o for positivity
and optimism that's the name of your
shoe it is because I believe in those
two things without the lesion everybody
who's listening you're not in the
optimism and positivity
you're you're in trouble in life because
there's a if you're looking for bad you
can find it but that doesn't mean
delusional and so practical optimism is
my religion
you the man Gary love having you on
anytime you know that you know I need to
get on before the jet season because
after I watch the second after I watch
the third preseason game which
ironically is against the Saints this
year instead of the Giants yeah I will
have a very educated hot take on there
oh look at a picture from your Instagram
I must have missed this you and you and
Le'Veon Bell how did a jersey exchange
already did you realize not only do we
have a Jersey exchange rich when we're
off the air I'm going to show you a text
exchange that basically black and white
proves that lay beyond Bell is a New
York jet because of me that's a hot you
know what that is that's actually 100%
pure facts
hashtag care yourself Gary congrats in
the cards and the sneakers and
everything else is necessary KB before
today's over to make sure I can say that
about the mix-up
you got it take care Gary that's Gary
Vee for more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app